understand the buying cycle of your
customer in business if you want to get
more sales it's important to understand
that before your customer is buying from
you they're buying from somebody else
and you can either make a partnership
with that person so they can pass you
new leads or it also just tells you who
is now ready to buy from you so if you
understand your customers buying cycle
it's a lot easier to know who your next
customer is going to be I love modern
success I love looking at famous
entrepreneurs and how they became
successful and one of my favorite
sources of Michael Dell you know now
he's his multi billionaire from the Dell
computers but one of his first ventures
was selling newspapers for a local paper
he wanted to sell subscriptions and he
didn't want to do what everybody else
did he didn't want to go door-to-door
knock on the door and say hey do you
want to buy a subscription to our
newspaper he thought it was really
inefficient big waste of time so what he
did was try to understand the buying
cycle of his customers and what he found
out was the people who were most ready
to buy were newly married couples moving
into the neighborhood those are the
people who wanted to buy subscriptions
to his newspaper so what he did was he
went down to the city and got a list of
all the people who are recently married
and moving into the neighborhood and he
created a targeted direct mail campaign
towards them because he knew these are
the people who wanted to buy his
newspapers who just reached out to those
people only instead of trying to blanket
the whole neighborhood what happened by
a senior year in high school he was
selling
$18,000 worth of commissions he made
$18,000 worth in commissions in his
senior year of high school when out
bought his first BMW paid cash for it
all of this happening because he
understood the buying cycle of his
customers so instead of beating your
head trying to target everybody not
having a great approach not getting
results in your sales efforts understand
who your customer is buying from what
actions they're taking before they buy
from you those people that they connect
with before you could again
referral partners for you but as a worse
case if you know they're buying from
them then the next step is they're ready
to buy from someone like you so make it
you instead of your competition believe
those are watching you like this video
please support me by clicking the link
below let me know where you have to say
I'd love to hear your comments on buying
cycles leave a comment below or ask the
question I'll make a video response and
click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon